okay I forgot to do an audio check but
hopefully the mic is okay I have an
impromptu mic stand here I have a chide
on't have a challenger he just
disappeared I was just gonna accept him
okay I'll wait for a challenger hello
Nathan the first viewer or the first
commenter hello checkmate we if anyone
wants to challenge me
just waiting for a challenge is a mic
recipe is this better
let me know if that's better I just
turned it down to minus 10 dB
is it better waiting for the delay
um much cleaner okay that's good to know
I was using this earlier
for like a video recording okay I have a
bunch of challengers wow this is so
conflicting um neither random number
between 1 and 4 but I don't know where
my phone is
wait a minute okay let's just play the
well play the patron 10 minute game big
gr Oh wonder if he's related to yarrow
jariabek good luck have fun what do I
want to play let's play an alkine
haven't played an alekhine in a while
and I'll play okay well well go into a
King's pawn opening but II five maybe
I've tricked him into opening that he
doesn't play or nights for Knights with
Bishop c4 I can take on e4 a classic
trap
and then d5
this brings back so much nostalgia like
childhood nowadays I just show all my
students this is the students who play
e5 because this happened so much in
scholastic chess
it's going to take on e5 I'll play Queen
Queen d5 I forget if Queen g5 is also a
move the Queen g5 is logical tak tak
defend
I'll probably take on c6 with something
it's not like a tactical trap it's more
of a positional trap where black
lack is getting some good control over
the center
okay so he took with the Knights
um but this looks like a nice position
for lack not the best pawn structure by
the great center
white wants to castle
I also might want to play d3 but not
right away
we're just gonna play Bishop d6
developing move
okay well allow this comment some reason
although mod blocks some notation
suggestions I don't know why but hello
to more people
hello chess trainee Jana of KZ some
really long name that I can't pronounce
Zeb oh oh double con I think I can recon
set
I'll Kaz okay
oh he plays g3 right away I just assumed
this would hang g2
taking on d3
if he takes back with anything I take oh
except he has bishop f3 and some some
lines hitting c6
so maybe I just Castle
hmm
I can't get away with taking on jutsu
if I Castle he takes I take
he castles
this might be a really equal position
but try and outplay him
yeah unfortunately there's no link
sharing I don't know why
just forgetting deleted
you
okay so he castles and now I have to try
and figure out how to make use of my
better development and better center
before he can get a reasonable position
some moves that come to mind or Queen h4
in Queen e5 also Bishop f5
if I play Queenie five
yes to play g3 I can continue initiative
with Bishop h3 we would have to play
rook e1
I could throw in some rook da door rook
e8
that
if she could also play f4 here that
seems a bit too weakening
you
okay
temper
I use Bishop f4 but he doesn't have
Bishop f4 cos b2 and hang so he's not
actually threatening to develop his
bishop
so maybe I just play rook e8
and then both bishops for him are just
kind of stuck
that true
there's some lion-like rookie a he could
try Bishop f4 Queen take Bishop take
take take I wouldn't see to I think
that's good because I counter-attack and
I'm I'm just up upon so rookie eight I'm
just gonna play Ricky AIDS
um and make him think because I don't
know what he's going to going to do here
because neither Bishop can move
especially this bishop is just pinned
and I'm nearly just done with
development my next move might be Rupp
d8 might be something also like we need
for
see three well he hasn't fixed the pin
now Queenie four looks very attractive
because then he would have to play f3
in there Queenie for f3 Bishop c5
King h1
looks so close to winning
in place some move like like Bishop f5
there or no I can't
or Carolina now that's too too exotic
okay so Queen e4 is one option just to
provoke f3
maybe something like Queenie for
and queen g6e ideas of sacking on g3
and also just play rook t8
I could also play Bishop c5
looks interesting too
I'm so conflicted
for f3 okay I'm gonna provoke f3 while I
can and I'll go for this idea
because you can't play Bishop d3 right
away because this queen would be
overworked and
he has to deal with this threat I'm not
sure how he deals with it
King f2 would be nice please flaky
enough too
it's probably the worst possible move in
the position
did he disconnect oh no he disconnected
oh he's reconnected okay and he's from
North Korea
it's kind of
garlic
this is rating
so please put some bullets
you
yeah I don't know what he's okay now I
know he got into Bishop f1
but can I just take on okay taking on g3
requires calculation
Bishop c5 is a move
there's so many enticing options here
see five in each one
I wanted to play rook - yep and then he
takes on Yates so if I take here he has
to take first I take and then he takes I
take
and we got some position like king h1
bishop take tick rookie five that's just
winning for a black or even rookie one
okay so Bishop take g3
take take
the only other option is for him to take
there but then I still have Ricki one I
think this is just a simple calculation
lay on them not missing anything I think
the fact that I have rookie one in so
many lines
it's just winning four back
um people wanna share chess calm
I guess that's allowed in the chats or
mods are allowed to share any link it's
true
yeah the Kasparov emote should be the
new POTUS I agree with Ariel
noggins says black is just winning I
probably have to agree with
this is a power of developing before
your opponent develops all his pieces
are in the back rink
you
also a nice example why pawn structure
is less important than Peace activity I
feel like a lot of players are just
scared of double pawns but when your
pieces are active they they offer some
compensation for pawn structure
when you get your mod status
yeah you just have to keep up your daily
viewing earn my trust somehow
uhh Mikasa thanks for the follow that's
the first follow of today livestream
labs open ok he plays rookie for what
does rookie for is giving me so many so
many options ok I have a number of
different types of checks
I could take on e4
find some horse mates
is always king each one
wait a minute if I play Bishop f4
I can take on e4 then play Bishop f4
so indecisive
okay I'll take on you for first
with stream labs not working
don't think Stream Labs is working
timed out
okay now e4 is hanging so just Bishop h4
I think is force mates
bishop
this would be one even okay
start with Bishop h4 yes to play here I
take he has to go back
and then maybe I go back he goes back
this is good enough but I don't think
it's force mates this feels like it
should be force mates
I'll repeat once
what then fungal told me to do
oh maybe just bishop no no not bishop f2
mmm
beer up t8
throw-in
I should play rook tio in my Queens on
e4
okay pieces are alive
and I'm up to pawns that's nice
and this queen is almost trapped I guess
you could play Queen b3
sad move you could play Queen e2
oh he takes a rock okay
- this line throw in this
keep it simple I'll play Bishop g5
have a queen against two bishops
you
I'm pretty sure there is a Nakamura calm
ski game where Nakamura had Queen and
two bishops and just didn't win because
Chomsky built some fortress but in this
case I have too many pawns
I'll take on a two first then it's hard
to stop the past a pond
what is with this chat so many messages
getting deleted
not sure what's going on
let's put the Queen on g5 and then run
with a pond
maybe see five at some point
of hanging a queen
the cream on b3
yeah so this will mainly be a viewer
challenge stream so people are welcome
to challenge me I don't know how long
it's gonna go probably until I get tired
I don't think I missed anything in
points anyway just to recap that game I
guess I tricked him into some opening
and then yeah this opening is supposed
to be at least equalizing maybe even
slightly better for black there's some
key variation first of all Bishop take
f7 King to guess 7 might take here I
think d5 is good for black and then one
of the key variations is that after
Bishop d3 Black has a very strong move
Knight b4
is supposed to be
like the way black gets some advantage
but I won't dig into it too deeply just
no night before and then people can
study this on their own so uh I have 14
pending challenges we're gonna play hero
because he was one of the first
challenges and he is a long time long
time supporter also created my discord
channel Thank You hero I have a decent
score against him is he gonna play a
London it's play E six Nathan with a
cheer
thanks for fixing whatever you're trying
to fix so why when I ended my stream
yesterday I told I was telling people
that I was gonna play this against the
London the next game uh just because
black is now winning a bishop this is
beautiful
since to this yesterday again some guy
who played a 4h for I play the reverse
London and he played G for entrapped my
bishop
like cradle and this is how you refute
the London u6h 5g5
if he means a play e4
I don't believe that because III is a
standard London player and move
ah so okay I can just take the bishop
and now I'm up a bishop
develop 906
nice trap
trap I move three against the London not
too often that happens so guy played h5
at Chicago open oh so he has experience
I wonder if was it the same position
I move one
okay so now this has a Queen's Indian
fuel to it right I'm gonna control the
center with my bishop
you
doesn't add to the Queen's engine fuel
it's actually a useful pawn to have like
if he castles queenside I can start
attacking
if you want to send me a challenge I'm
chess you can I think you can type in
the Lee chess command and then yeah
Nathan is answering Thank You Nathan
I'm going to continue developing
to develop first
just going to play Bishop e7 to make
sure there's less pressure against the
e-file
also because my bishop doesn't have any
other attractive squares
a complete development
I have threats of this
also ideas of maybe listen this
still ideas of this
take with the d-pod
opening up the Queen c3 is normal
debating between Quincy five and 95
you
let's weigh 95
if I play Quincy five I think the Queen
would get kicked around
95 very clear threats if he plays g3
that makes my aya [ __ ] much happier
what he's going to do here
would be a triple Fork
in some regard
chest network used to play on chess cube
really
I failed on chessick you maybe once in
my life
okay so he plays Bishop a6 now Knight f4
is very attractive
it could get weird it's not that for he
could take on b7 I take on E - he takes
I put here he takes and then he is oh he
has two nights for a queen
and queen c8 is also possible I'm just
gonna play Queen see it I don't mind
trades
Queen comes to be seven I'm happy to
Castle queenside hello to excise sparks
good to see you back
after 3g5 white should've played yeah
white sugar played Bishop e5 at six
Bishop e2
um I think that's what I tried yesterday
in my game but I still got crushed and
it was reversed
you
you
unmov'd three
I played h5 on
by page 5 on move to the h5 on move to
is tricky because it looks pointless but
the idea is to prevent III
you
you
you
so he's probably the bathing whether
it's a take or to retreat but if he
retreats some night afore
would be possible
it's so pleasant being up a piece
because it's all up to light to try and
I get counterplay and all I have to do
is just hold on to things improve the
position
now my queen is feeling cathode
Nathan you won but you won the under-20
100 section of Chicago class blitz
at first I I didn't see the Blitz parts
as I check the standings
but I didn't realize you played did you
play the open section or the uh the main
event - or just the Blitz
weenie for
you'll just castle
you
you
like normally black or light would light
to Castle kingside
but the fact that I have a G file and
pawn on each five probably discouraging
him so he could Castle queenside
but I could also have some Queens that
attack to like Queen a6
there might be some tactical shots
noggin has to go ok bye toilet noggin
picking up the kiddos from school
it's 11:23 p.m. so you're probably in
the u.s. somewhere okay I'm going to
play Queen a six and tactical shots
might include
something like Bishop a3 I don't know if
this does anything
doesn't do anything the idea would be to
somehow exploit c3
so I could play queen bee five
I'm not sure if Queen b5 is like a good
move or just a hopeful move
okay I'm gonna play Queen p5 at least
try and make him think
you
Oh mas and thanks for the follow-up
doing so much analysis but the ponent is
probably watching the stream doesn't
that reveal my tricks I mean I didn't
reveal my first trick with H 5g5
so how hurt out I mean yeah I'm usually
aware that my opponents can watch the
stream and if they're watching then
there's some delay so they have to wait
some time until they hear what I say
maybe it's proving to be the cases
schemer I have some nice time advantage
okay so Rick see one
I just played this
running mates he plays this
over complicate things
he wants to play c4
[Music]
thanks for the follow Irish man
okay I'm gonna just be boring and
retreats and then maybe improve my queen
and unimproved his queen and maybe even
go for a queen trade someday anywhere he
goes
there's no sound there should be sound
wait
okay it's probably it's probably your
settings and not my settings Bishop a3
was tempting but Knight b3 would then be
attacking the bishop we go back to this
position Bishop a 3-bike b3 has a double
threat of be take a 3 and C 4 and I
didn't want to mess with that so he
plays Queen e1
you
I'm still up a piece let's improve my
rook
the G to Paulina
I forgot I have Queen t3 as well you
could Square for the Queen
rain Rabi thanks for the follow
you
so there is a two second increments
still matters
okay so g3 was kind of expected now I'm
very tempted to play Bishop a3 because
there's tactics
so a bishop a three let's see what he
does
you
you
you
I'm threatening mate so there's only a
few ways for him to defend rook yeah I
Roxy to his investment I was hoping for
a night b3 and then I would have these
work possibilities but rooks you too
I might have to just retreat again
wanna be on a three
I tried
and the great thing is that I can be
patients
made for him to give me some opportunity
kind of waiting for him to play c4
because then that would give me the be
Foursquare for my nights
and probably sometime soon I'll put my
queen on that five or it's just a bit
more effective
Bishop f8 h6 I honestly didn't consider
that well I like my bishop on e7 because
it's slightly more centralized
so you stopping queen r5
but the nights kind of out of play I'm
going to play Queens III
I mean if I really want to go crazy I
could consider some move like rook take
t4 he's tempting me rooked ad for CJD
for night before esta play like Queen D
wonder Queen c1
yeah that's probably too much I'm gonna
play 95 here
popping nineth four and I have ideas the
night before
also ideas of Bishop g5
seems like there's going to be a lot of
ways to increase pressure
you
and whites pieces are kind of so sad and
just so passive
you won
I'm so attempted to play night before
probably night db4 is better because if
he takes I can take on d4
pressurizing the rook
but then he plays either four we trade a
bunch of things
I'm going to play h4 here
kind of just increasing the tension I'd
be happy to trade off the bishop for
Knights
also may be threatening h3
and he is 91 that would just be funny
but maybe he'll play it
you
continuing to retreat
it's hard to retreat when so many pieces
are just on the second and first rank
riki one is this trapping the night
he would have no he doesn't have work
III so here
um thanks for the follow whoever you
were I missed the names so if you want
to say hi in the chats feel free h3 I
think 9 f 400 or 93 got about 93
I still have night before whenever I
want
so have Bishop g5 ideas I'm gonna play
Bishop g5
III more and then also improving one of
my pieces even further
I like my peace coordination compared to
whites peace coordination
hello to ahd 1311
foreplay f3o
mentioned and Fievel I need to play King
be eight or been fine gold will be man
I'm I mean
really careful make Ben five old mad
especially if it's just not playing the
moves he tells everyone to always play
okay so now White has every second drink
square filled by a piece don't know if
that's relevant in any way
the knight is pinned to the Queen and
the rook is pinned to the king
this Knight is kind of dominated
what to do night before looks
tragic Massacre for whites because he
takes and then I take and then
everything's pinned and forked
I'm not going to pre-move
I'll just admire this this position
I'm at least winning back like a pawn
and a rook for the two knights so I'll
still be up material
I didn't really calculates I just
assumed that I'm winning more like this
rook is just hanging
it's positioned so funny just a clump of
white pieces okay we'll continue to
trade now this night is is sort of
pinned to a checkmating square
I for is a good move
take care first
okay so clock is up a rook life is good
g3s hanging this night is still pinned
g3 can't really be defended MEAP remove
this
ginger Mamba ooh I didn't see 94
have hmm okay I have this
like to calculate meat
Brook take a three
also play this move
you
yeah this is just simplifying
I have Roque one
I just read Nathan's comment Ricca one
King take rook to a3 king b1 and then
pen feingold would be happy
91 I think this is the simplest
please make Ben Feingold happy and
planking be one no okay
well like to trap the night
you
now to trap the Knights okay let's just
activate the king
restrict his king
the night
you
okay a good game here oh sorry if I
caused you pain it just looks like a
painful position for white after move
three starting on move three yeah this
is how you refute the London h5 and g5
yeah I think Bob London is just now a
dead opening well of course why could
have gotten compensation with Bishop e5
someone suggested this Bishop e2 and
then
would probably I don't know what I would
do after Bishop e2 I would decide
between h4 taking and then
some lines I have to play Qing Yi seven
Rick recommended for
wait average has has recommended
something this position
Everts recommendations are crazy because
he's he prepares for like all these
crazy sidelines but I'm still surprised
he would recommend something it's h5
it's crazy play against better opponents
ouch
shots fired against hero
um my London DVD does not cover this
line because I just discovered this line
yesterday but maybe I'll have to make a
part two to cover this line
um play a better opponent okay I'll
accept the highest-rated opponent out of
everyone who's challenging me 17:11 ooh
Twenty twenty one twenty eight twenty
one sixty-four anyone higher
okay I'm playing the highest rated
player 2164 no 2280
okay playing this guy
almost as high rated as me this name
sounds really familiar
I think I was playing bullit against him
earlier
good luck
I play let's play e4 is something new
the other three will play a Ponzi honey
opening Queen a4 see how well-prepared
he is
was sort of what he's doing there should
be five
this could get really crazy really
quickly
take and then castling I think it's been
a while since I've actually studied like
the main line here I did play this in a
tournament once again sam-7
and he beat me like really quickly even
though I had like a good position from
the opening one of the main ideas here
is that if I play earth black lady for
like an counter-attack with c4 there's
some interesting initiative
I'm gonna try and refrain from saying
anything more
okay
German people in the chats Bishop e6
I've actually had a game in this Bishop
e6 I don't think is a great move because
of d4
I played this
some years ago in a tournament where I
got my second IM norm I believe
and what my opponent ended up having to
play Bishop d7 within the next like two
or three moves there's a problem here
white is threatening this in this
a fork the pieces
you
and there's some positions where black
would like to play a six but then I can
still play c4 and the a6 pawn is pinned
so this is nice back is thinking
Queen d7 I think the best move is to
take I taken Bishop d7 because here I
think I can just win upon
taking on e5 looks decent
he's still massively pinned
hmm okay so he's treating this lake of
gambits
you
can't really win the a7 pond
but I can leave my pond here because
it's defended
to figure out how to complete
development I'll just play Bishop III
maybe I'm threatening this
if he plays this I might consider
sacking in be 893
Quincy
ecigs take take taking be aids maybe
queen bee five first King AIDS
Nathan with some bits play g4 right now
no
self-destructs um she for her would be a
terrible move is he threatening to take
the bishop because I have this and then
Bishop b8 but then he has knight c6
but maybe I can play 93 here here and
then I take I'm threatening smother
inmates he plays this and then I 97 take
bishop take and then he can't defend
um let's do it because it splits hero
with a cheer gee why are you guys saying
g4 it's like one of the worst moves to
play
effort more bits listen to Nathan
I'm so confused
okay so he's attacking the bishop
I'm gonna consider taking
maybe I just leave the tension
hey this
such a weird position
someday I'll play g4
does not when I'm being attacked
I wanted to sack on a six but I wasn't
sure about lines where I here's this
immediate Queen see a queen bee seven
also if I took on a six and that
previous position he hadn't I take III
so he plays Knight b6 now I can just
simplify everything and be up upon
but is there anything better rook t1
maybe
could play rugby one
you
g4o this time it's someone else saying
Stephen Stephen is Daedalus
um well now g4 maybe makes sense
like control these two squares
I stopped Bishop h3
harmful is
no he's attacking like bishop
take
I wonder if my opponent is just like
bribing everyone to cheer so you can win
this this casual game
okay I think I can take on t8
what is this 500 bits from Stephen
saying g4
like can someone explain why you want me
to play g4
I take on a six
I play bishop wait Bishop c4 take tick
is b5
now the problem is he's threatening this
and to take the pawn
I have a funny idea though and it's not
g4 I'm gonna play rip d1
the idea is that if he takes he has
triple pawns and then I would win his
queen I forgot about Bishop take a three
but I don't think that matters
because take Oh
doesn't matter
is defending this
if this were like an over the board game
I would act really confident try and
Bluff him but okay so now I'm down at
peace
I imagine she got a bad position without
fighting g4
but there's still comp here
because I have the smooth
there's still some attack b5
attacked
pretty much it
okay I'll play g-41 that makes sense
when and if it makes sense but not right
now III III looks decent
whoa
counter-attack
wait I'm down on time too
okay gotta move
he's
I was so distracted by everyone wanting
me to play g4
hmm
you
okay I'm gonna defend the c3 pawn and
try and bring my Knights to attack I
just want to get my knight to b5
gotta get up on time too
target b6 as well I don't think he can
defend me five unless he plays that so
I'll play Knight B five and now Queen
take B six invading
yeah let's move the rook over
okay I can do
and destroy or nuts
okay I gotta move much quicker
you
well about queen g4 do I get credit for
that mu now g4 yes g4 what a great move
trapping the bishop I don't know if that
was a trap Oh
you
you
no I flagged at least like white g4o
with a sad moment to flag I should have
kept Queens on the board and just keep
checking him because if King g7 I would
have rook G 1 G 4 turned out to be a
good move I think
it wasn't actually a bishop traffic into
sub Z 3 but it was good enough I was all
calculated ahead of time to that's
unfortunate that's a good position I got
careless around here though
rookie ones careless move just retreat
the bishop
or go into his territory with Bishop
Bishop ei probably runs into Bishop take
a three thanks hero 400 more bits okay
well that was sad we'll play someone
else
I'll play I'll play I come from Tetris
he's been waiting the longest
good luck you guys play them once before
what Camus at
oh that was I have some big memories of
that game okay we'll play e5 [ __ ] good
luck have fun I mean we'll play a Petrov
you
ooh another four nights g5 wait is G
five playable here
g5s playable sure
because I opened the G file there's
actually some idea in the not the Petrov
with the Philidor to play some early g5
wrote g8 now he's confused
Richey AIDS
um yeah when you give away pawns you
then you you gain open files that's the
whole point and now we have a four
nights with my reckon g8 so now is
Bishop can Tavella still theory yeah
ooh he developed his bishop
deep opening crap
I like this opening g5s a nice move
style of Shibboleth
I played Bishop c5 here
just go for the kill without recapturing
I want to be somewhat reasonable okay
Bishop c5
sometimes in order to win quickly you
have to play dubious moves
this might be overly dubious oh and sink
girl thanks for following
would you agree that chess comm tends to
be a little rougher on newer players and
me chess what you mean by rougher
yeah actually don't know how to answer
that I'm not sure what he's asking
meaning like our the player is just
better this just calm probably has a
stronger player base
um but that's more towards the top top
levels
not necessarily to the newer players
okay D for what to do I think I can just
take
this is attacked and
attacks
and this is of course the long-term
targets
I see your message regarding Smith Mora
analysis I have some vague memory of
seeing Metz
but I may have liked glance did it
looked at it and then got distracted
couldn't just forgot about it sometimes
that's a problem especially with HS
messages send it to me again and I'll
take a look
Oh are they for
and a four
you
I've bishop before check
and c3 is gonna get really weird
already weird
you
there's also some line where I trap
those nights I'm going to start with
Bishop b4
not chopping is my singing c3 take take
and then be five years night c5
you
someone asking you I still teach at st.
Louis chess club
when when I've taught at st. Louis chess
club it's their their residency position
which is like a rotating rotating
position where a different title player
will do like their weekly lectures and
every every few weeks to a month there's
a new player who who fills the position
so I'll actually be back next week to
start or to do three weeks of teaching
so there might be some new new YouTube
videos at least for their channel on the
horizon
um but there's also there's also a sink
felt cup and st. Lewis rapid and blitz
which are which is happening in August
as well so it's going to be a cool time
to be in st. Louis
okay I think I can take and then just
win back the piece and be happy
you
and he can win upon
it'll be equal material
I'll take with the deep on most likely
you
five with the Knights
Asaf referring to this position
you
ginger Mamba I do give private lessons I
have a coaching profile on me chess I
also have a website and there should be
some commands to to get links to those
Oh can I take on e4 I could have taken
on e4 but I don't want to open the
e-file because that could very easily
backfire Queen e2 bishop h3 looks really
fun
this looks like some kind of bug house
positions and scheme does not want to be
on f1
you
yeah probably that my websites easiest
way if you go to forget what it's called
like I've instruction or chest coaching
you'll find it
joana try is another chest reamer
good to see you Johanna
to do after Knight g5
interesting move
um I think my threat here is this amend
this so also if this I can just take it
if my queen were on d7 and i had one
extra move i could play this and then
mate on g4
but okay he's gonna do something to try
and defend
these are the most expected moves
I'll be pretty shocked if you place
anything else
ooh
I'm shot
but what to do
I mean now I kind of just want to play
this set up my threats
can also do this and he does this
if I do this he does this I go back
that helps
okay this is kind of a hopeful move
but I actually think it's one of the
best moves
because I'm also planning to just Castle
queenside get my King safe get the other
rook into the game
let's see what happens
I think b5 would only help him
will you please five so now there is
some calculation because if I do this
you can do this
so maybe I'll do this setting up the
double checkmate
you've never watched chess on Twitch
this is is this really exhilarating I
don't think my stream is supposed to be
exhilarating but I hope some fight that
some people find it that way I mean I
just wanna okay I want to do this I
don't think he's watching cuz he would
first of all he would not be confused
with g5 given that I was incentivized to
play it
hey oh it's not double check me it would
only be double check
so where's the kill rook g1 kingi to
Queenie for Queen III
I could just take the night's for free I
was so like fascinated with all these
checks
I forgot the night was hanging
you
and now I'm threatening made into with
this this
or maybe this would be more brutal
this is a hard position to defend
well thanks for the the novelty who
recommended g5 the Nathan air hero
scrolling up
can't find it there's too many comments
you
it was me of course it was Nathan okay
that makes sense
you
so here's just under three minutes to
realize his fate and to cry
thanks for the hundred bits being
okay may than to
nice final position I made full use of
that G file
after this game ends I want to check to
see if g5 is a novelty I would think it
is okay
of I don't know what to say
gonna say let's go to analysis board go
to the opening Apple TV
oh it's been played before
but white has won every time this is
first time
g5 has been played in black is one tenet
Juicin thanks for the follow where where
is the stats
oh I think leach ass only shows like a
certain number of moves or maybe there
is some transposition like maybe this
and then
I don't even know
maybe g5 here
yeah I think leech s just refuses to
recommend some moves which are in as
popular
and that was pleasant okay ah new
opponent
there is someone who I wanted to play
still challenging me though
yeah I only he's still challenging me
when I started the stream I had one
challenge and I was about to click on it
and then it just disappeared
um so too bad for that guy I will play
the guy who shares a similar name to me
Simon Rosen Simon Rosen al I'm only
playing him because I like his name
yeah Magisto if you want to challenge me
again
I didn't see you there oh here is well
too bad playing Simon let's fly a more
normal opening this time I'll take
recommendations if people want to say or
say what they play against d4 I could
try and go for something
good luck
probably watching
he heard I like like his name uh chief
I'm not playing g5 again we're gonna
play a bingo
because bingo sounds fun you play a
bingo against Knight f3
try and play a bloomenfeld
I can't say the names again sign of
three
well this isn't going to be a bank oh
this is going to be I don't even know
what to call this a reverse Queens
gambit accepted
with Bishop III I can take idea being
that I have Queen 85
we only have Queen 85 okay I'm gonna
just bluff and hope he doesn't do what
he's probably gonna do
fleet mental lapse I just assumed yet
never assumed so now I have to fight
back down a piece this is a rated game
I was probably better off playing g5
under a piece
that's what this does to me like after
after with a previous game just lose
track of reality so hopefully this will
be an interesting demonstration of how
to come back from a really bad position
I'm going to start with this
I have to untangle somehow
I also just want to make him think
and with this move I'm okay applying
pressure here and here and I might want
to play this next
some triple triple attack of some sort
I can't castle I would love to castle
but this bishops on d6
I have Queen Queen f6 possibilities to
Mindi for probably a good move let's
take
you
I don't even have a pawn for the piece
I'm just gonna trade Queens
ten that I'm not down a piece and I'll
just develop normally and not give him
anything more for free we'll have some
like Hedgehog setup
and the key with these positions is to
avoid trades at all costs playing a6 to
avoid any night b5 shenanigans with
pressure against g6 and 97 ideas
I might even go for it this souther just
try and be solid
you
you
and the one whoa what is e five okay so
D 5 is a natural response I was about to
say the one good thing I have about this
position is this half-open C file and
that's what I'm going to try and use
I know the bishop isn't that effective
on b7 but I just want to bring a rook to
see it maybe even miss for up to c8
start with this
and I am sorry to say this but I'm gonna
have to use time as some sort of factor
it help me win this so if he wants to
beat me he's gonna have to play quicker
affecting f4 year
so you should probably defend the pie
my-my-my sorry yeah maybe I shouldn't be
sorry I'm just sorry that I have to
resort to time rather than playing good
moves to beat beat the opponent
but it is like a factor that sometimes
you have to to use especially when you
have a bad position try and um at least
keep some time advantage okay I'm gonna
play h5 and the nice thing is that
White's extra piece isn't like that
powerful because it's such a closed
position
and I don't have too many exploitable
weaknesses
okay maybe I'll double up on the C file
whatever pawn break he goes for I will
continue to close down the position
now let's question what to do I would
love to get this Knight to g4 but that's
kind of difficult to play f5 but I don't
want any pawn trades Thank You Dirk for
the follow
so maybe I just wait
let's wait with 98 so this is insane
thanks for the follow
yeah I'm gonna wait and see what he
comes up with I'm preventing see for
these pawn breaks are under control
I'm actually not sure what he's going to
do here
and if he thinks for a minute I'll be
happy with that too haha 98 is a true
movement of a champion so it's very true
and then of course 97 back
but I can't make it seem like I'm just
doing nothing I have to make it seem
like I have some D plans
teemo's thanks for the follow
I don't really have any deep plans
my pieces are are optimized I think
I just can't get to g4
you
you
you
especially with his last MIT was like
Brook c-141 King F - doesn't seem like
he has a fan either
it's kind of a funny situation to be in
oh he takes okay so he's going for
tactics
which is possible now I'll be down the
exchange
and two pods
Oh
so the position is transforming now
probably in his favor
you
but I'm still alive
now I have some deep plans like nurse
and nurse and this and this and this
that's how I get to G for his heart is
pumping it's another thing which I've
realized is
a player of of his rating isn't just not
used to having just such a huge
advantage against a player of my rating
so it's an unfamiliar situation and
sometimes that causes nerves or
increased heart rates
but bring my bishop I want my bishop to
go to e4 somehow
you
he's planning this
to do to close things down I'll put the
King on e6
deep breaths yeah when you're nervous
just take some deep breaths
helps but the classic advice
problem is the spawn is gonna be weak
it's already weak
gonna double up
he only has two minutes left
so I just have to trick him for
two more minutes
with a bad position
okay I'm just gonna give up the pond
because peace activity is more important
hopefully I'm not blundering anything
more I don't think I am I want to bring
my night into the game put my Knights on
the square and then maybe here
you might be winning more stuff
you
I can play a waiting game again because
everything's defended I'll just do this
this is a pure waiting move
he's not meeting me
you
what would I recommend to play against
are ready opening this is not the time
to answer that question as I'm I'm in
serious trouble
you
you
I don't want to take the night but I
kind of have to who he takes with pawn
well this gives me some hope now I have
some mating attack
yes his pawns are blocking out his rook
I have to be
lover with how I execute this
you
I just saw he he's capable of pre moving
okay let's start with Bishop f5 because
I don't want him to take on g6 and then
this is a target pawn
care about lamby pawn
you
that's a good move
I play this
seems wrong but
or it can I have to watch my time
situation too
so for this
you
now my heart is pumping
can't do this
these defending stuff I can take this
I'm also defending stuff can win the
b-pawn
in such a weird position
that's a really good move
it's a really good move
hmm
Oh No
okay I'm in some big trouble here
you
you
you
I'm in some really big trouble
but I'm gonna fight
I might even fight here
do this
you
this is really unfortunate
[Music]
don't kill me
oh no my rating my beautiful over 2,300
rating
you
you
it's pink for 20 more seconds please
take my bishop please
uh okay it's good enough to checkmate me
nicely played well played
oh man I think this is almost a maximum
rating points you can lose I was feeling
comfortable like even around here or
maybe not comfortable but I was feeling
hopeful
a three that maybe king g4 was a feather
shot I was just trying to made him like
this
Brooke c6 was I think one of the only
moves
you
but okay when I'm threatening mates it's
uh I don't think it's a hard move to
find my rook f2 is another good move
well played
a rook f1 any other any more hope I
could have had probably nuts oh that's
tough I've lost I've lost too many games
today
that's a lot of rating points to lose
though press f to pay respects yeah okay
so this is a lesson in the opening that
you can't get careless
especially with
I'm just assuming tactics work take take
25 doesn't work because of B 4 so what's
the move here maybe just 986 986 is
probably a decent move
analysis board
you
okay so I'm not alone this this has been
played by a black before her very high
winning percentage for whites
so after a bishop yet night a6 looks
nice okay
lesson learned tough game 23 pending
challenges
okay I'll play Magisto
as he's been waiting forever
good luck Magisto
that last game this
make me slightly tilted but I'll try and
play some some sort of instructive chess
I'm gonna probably be a lot more
aggressive than normal though
and swine and playing the Petrov
Oh Ariel has also been waiting forever
maybe I'll just do a similar you want me
to play just one game at a time or do
you want me to do a simultaneous
I'm not sure if d5 is theory but it
looks playable he takes I can play e4
if this I do this already threatening
this Simon Simon prefer to play me
there's a lot more Simoes
Bishop f5 probably what I'll do is like
some kind of let's I'm all I don't want
to play
for like four more hours so I've made
the mistake in the past where I have
like thirty second increment and the
games just take forever
Nathan's gonna try a 15-person
simultaneity know when you're doing that
and I'll probably just raid you if you
stream it's
ninety-two
it's complete development but I throw in
this move trying provokes III
they'll probably retreats
you
8:30 Central Time
wait that's
try and do the math it's 12:30 here
Central times seven hours behind so in
three more hours okay so the reason why
I provoked
c3 is because now I can take on c3 and
win upon or I could take on f2 in when
upon because d3 is not defended I'll
take on c3
but I want to open that file for him
Oh his name is like a goat
Magisto so Magisto
oh and he's in South Africa cool
oh wait I'm in the same time zone the
South Africa
I guess that kind of makes sense South
Africa is like directly south of Prague
to look at the map
I don't think I'll be streaming for
three hours but I'll try and be awake at
that time to host you
I don't know if I'm gonna be awake at
that time though
let's retreat the bishop
uh Papon not used to being up material
his games
now I just want to castle
you
in the same time zone is somewhere I've
never heard of okay
Prague is really nice the weather is
good the food is great
I played in some chests I didn't other
day where it was actually like it was a
variant but it was still normal chess is
just you play the same opponents in two
separate games at once so it's like a
two-player simultaneous in' it's called
basket s it's pretty cool
I'm gonna play does that work 95
is there some annoying pressure
it could also play d4 play d4
then if he pins like if we're can he
move the night if he plays this I'll
probably pull it Carlson and do some
positional Queen sac for a rook and a
minor got a pawn if he does this and
we'll have a normal more normal position
well please play my left lung that would
make things a lot more fun
um yeah Baskar boskie i don't know how
you pronounce it but nathan has spelled
it correctly
I don't know how popular ask chess is if
it's just like
in Europe that people play it's because
I've never heard of it until like
recently
well I can still pull a Carlson
if there's people who are watching who
don't know what I'm talking about
Carlson had a really nice game yesterday
against David navara or he did something
like this this gave away a queen kind of
out of nowhere but rook I think it was a
rook Knight in pawn
um it was completely okay he was white
as different position but he had some
nice initiative I have some nice
initiative
I guess it makes sense if it comes from
Spain
d 3 let's try and meet the king
first time seeing that won't buy
this time seeing the Queen sack
this just looks fun 97 95
not sure how meat is gonna happen
put the Ricardian first
because this is the only open file this
Queens on d1 and then I'll try and
improve somehow I might like play rook
d4 take away more squares from the king
and then there's some potential mate
okay I finally see one potential mate of
97-95 the King comes here and then rook
h4 with mates
executing it could be difficult
so I
six-year king h3 and then this g4 and
then I could just take the pawn oh but
he is king f2
you
you
I'll probably just continue with 97 just
ignore this move
if he takes on that seven I take with
Bishop
you
so the time situation is not looking so
good for whites is it actually a sack
yes it's debatable I mean I did give
away a queen
I did get something in return
but if you give away something
still sacrificing I know
it okay let's do this
do I play rook t4 first
maybe rook t4 first
just to be slightly trickier
cuz I don't know if we'll actually see
the threats okay I have to get out of
check the threat is still there he
defended against a threat
and he's attacking the bishop
okay I have some funny idea I'm gonna
play 9f5
I'm expecting King age three
whoo King F for what is this
just makes my head hurt
so now these two pieces are hanging but
his kings on f4 so Bishop d6 comes to
mind
oh my Rick's hanging to have so many
things hanging
comes to mind
I do have to be very careful
you
you
king of organics
affected
I see some line which could just like
simplify that simplifies into an endgame
room up upon
I'm gonna go for that I'm not saying it
cuz he might be watching
yeah okay we'll see what happens
- in the chats it showed g6
the point is now I'm winning
efore and probably winning his queen
Brooke and Bishop
yeah I think it's only called a
sacrifice if you end up winning the game
they end up losing the game let's just
call that blunder
that's the rule okay I should consider
h5 but then he is king g5 so I'll just
take
and then we get some position I'm just
up upon
you
with great winning chances I should be
careful though Knight g5 could be coming
a g5 is actually really annoying I'm
gonna play h6
because rook a3 Knight g5 he would be
threatening mates
oh no he would be threatening mates
but okay now I'll play your okay three
you
or
activate the king
try and restrict his night
you
we can trade
I want to play this or this
you
I could remove this
you
you
you
pass funds must be pushed
you
keep pushing
you
let's play this first
you
you
you
you
it's nice when I have just so many task
pawns
okay now eat
the threat
you
oh that's not meats because D 1 is not
legal
that's unfortunate
there's the quickest meats
you
okay Magisto good game oh I do want to
show one kind of funny line which could
have happened I was back when he played
this king f4 move if he had instead
played King h3 I was so excited to play
Bishop e6 and I'm pretty sure this is
winning in all lines I could be mistaken
but the point would be that okay I have
some discoveries against his King if he
were to go for this move Knight f6 to
attack the bishop I was gonna play the
very subtle and quiet move Keeney cheats
with idea that he can't take the bishop
because rook h4 mates and then meanwhile
what else does he do maybe he would have
g4 but then okay
actually this would still be complicated
maybe I would have work III
I don't know that was a fun position
okay I'm gonna do a Simon so for
everyone challenging me
I'm sorry Joanna tries wants to play one
minute crazy house
okay well I'll do is I'm gonna host the
Simon play one crazy house game and then
accept some people for the sign on
so Simon host new cyma
okay only standard make it random ten
minutes plus wait no
five minutes plus five
up to five people and that way we'll get
more Simon more quickly creates um it's
open I'll share the link in the chat in
the meantime
oh she's still challenging me but I want
to make a new tab there you go
okay so while the Simon's open I'm gonna
play this one game
good luck Joanna tries
uh try and get this over with quickly
are you here maybe she's not here pre
move something what's my favorite piece
I like the pawn are pawns considered
pieces pawns are just future pieces
okay I'm gonna give Joanna say ten more
seconds
turn okay I'm sorry Joanna she's
probably just left or fell asleep abort
dr. Simon okay
well except in patient duck because he's
the first person to join and then we'll
just do random people so accept accept
accept accept one two three four okay
five players good luck
um
and let's move somewhat quickly
ready gambit was first
don't accept them the last person to
join I'm sorry if I did okay this is
going to be hard to multitask but I'll
try my best
let's play some moves
I'm gonna be aggressive in some games
because I want to win quickly to have
time for other games
is actually a bit laggy so this might be
hard to keep up with
we'll see okay so we have a Spanish we
have a budapest declined
this v7
you
the Budapest is not an opening people
should decline can have some other
gambit this is some awkward period sir
Kings Indian Google London let's play c5
c3
like that's losing upon
you
over key one maybe not losing upon
no any Theory here I'm just gonna play
9:06 excise sparks with ten bits g4 to
the strat oh no don't distract me please
uh he plays 92 near if he's seen okay
I'll play a six I'm wondering if he's
seen my course I recommend 92 see 3d
five
mmm let's play d5 again
play the Weslie so variation
[Music]
oh no I just blundered like terribly
that was the worst move I've played in a
while
we'll take it spawn
and I'm playing against a good player
too that's really bad
okay I'm gonna lose one game I'm just
down the piece
other games I like my positions like we
know six
on g5
such a sad position no g8
should III
you
why you have black eye I have black in
some games because I set random colors
so
and algorithm
magic
what is going on here
want to take on d4 but
unsound
g3 is castle
my knight does not belong on d2
have fun ooh he just gave me a night's
okay I'll take on c3 and take on d5
Bishop d3 let's play f5
classic idea castle um ooh I don't think
I can take on d5 because this Queen is
defending
so I'll play this threatening Bishop
efore Queen d2
I think I just fluttered more material
night's attacks let's play ask for
from point ig5 it's unsound but that's
life
yeah this is bad Queen if maybe Queen B
5 attacking the P pond
I can take
okay so some positions are good for me
this position I really like if you just
hang a bishop you just hung a bishop
also can I take care
wait this is complicated
let's take the bishop first I have hope
now this is equal material
work on e7 versus
take this way the minutes
this bishop Lundy three
and not g2i
following some line which is really good
when the bishops on g2 but now I'm
realizing it's really bad when the
bishop is not on g2 us to play g6
um well I can take this I'm not even
losing anything
spewpa laid-back
to cure okay now Queenie seven
some of these positions of the bishop
here
a lot of these positions I just have to
trust my first instinct
you
now can I take
then Queen g7 not pretty
you
you
five games still going um it's probably
a good move to play rook f6
now Bishop d5 looks really strong I'm
attacking the Queen I'm attacking the b2
pawn
it's good for whites
pushing pawns
okay do my take or do I play c4
place c4
this is really bad so tragic
you
okay now I take I'll have a decent night
against a relatively bad bishop
Queeny to double attack
hey I won the game I don't know which
game I won but I did win a game I'm very
happy with the Queen trade in that
position I wants to play h5
you
okay all allow it's put the rook here
he's attacking stuff
well I have three pieces for her rook oh
how that happened
now this position I'm down a few pawns
but this I'm alive
students
at 6:00
always play at 6:00
bring the Queen back
you
no I hung a piece out
it's a problem when you're you have so
many pieces it's easy to hang them well
I still have two pieces for a rook
okay that's not a free pond
good try though let's put the bishop
somewhere more useful
you
so he's living this annoying pin but
they work here maybe
at night
five key 7
by five and when the H pond
some of these games are still fights for
left
okay this is a completely crushing
position I think
six creating lift Bishop c2 getting rid
of the loofah
just go into the sending
Castle queenside
right when the halftime
ah that's the past pun
bring the King in
blockade thanks for the follow shredded
wet
throwing the check
creates more loops
what do I do I'll create some lift to
King fritter in okay this should be over
very very very soon
be starting with queen g6 attacked the
pawn
I could trade and then he has no more
pin
if I'm winning the rook they're very
close to winning something I'm gonna put
the bishop on that five take a free pawn
unstoppable mates
pine
oh it's is it unstoppable mates yes
take a free rook
active King
okay now I kind of want to take but then
it's ops of color bishops
but they'll have work a chain he can't
defend the pond
another free rook
whereas my mates I have so many
different pawn captures let's do this
fun
can I meet the king somehow if he goes
to be four I'm just gonna play a 5
because pawn storm active rook attack
the pawn I really have to manage my time
96 what one of the monster Knights let's
prevent rook g7 check the King uh what
is going on three pawn
no he defended the pawn let's attack it
again free pawn be queen
a pawn trade what's the increment oh
it's five second increment okay that's
not too bad so I have won two games
there's three still going I'm winning
this game I'm winning this game and I
should be winning this game
another game the skin which I'm not
winning but I took upon okay how do I
meet the king I'll bring the light to f4
put the rook there
bring the bishop back
a check
okay
hey it's mate in the center good game
no this is going to be tough
what to do I have to take and then push
the spawn
you
you
take all the pawns let's put the bishop
here because
play Bishop f1 like been Feingold has
always taught me
oh he's so tricky tricky person
okay so I have one game left so this
could be a long game especially with
increments and see what happens when he
pawns is he up he's up two pawns but he
just gave me a free pond he wants to
play d5
I can about that
and
I don't think he saw Bishop f1
you
um okay but black is still worse I
should probably improve the king my king
wants to be here here so let's start
with this
still have to watch out for time
his king is running in
or is it improve the king further
whoa is overextending kind of because
now I can play this and then perhaps II
too
might be playing for a win I have a C
pawn it's improved my king
ah so he's being active with his king
this check
this is a position all three results are
possible which is probably what I want
not entirely sure what's going on
he goes back okay
I can keep activating my king
cept if I play here that I'm no longer
attacking the pawn and I'm low in time
so what to do
the bishop on g3 maybe
some point I'll probably play this and
then maybe what make him this way
you
you
crazy position I have to win this game
to keep the perfect
Simon score
and he's a bit stuck like both the king
his King has stuck hookers tied down to
the pawn bishop has tied down to the
Fang this pawn these pawns are fixed by
my amazing pawn on e6 that's great one
pawn fixing three pawns okay so he's
trading a seven for b5
throwing rippy six probably yeah
and now I go for this
you
and now he can win e6 but his Bishop is
attacked
I'll probably play something like this
maybe I shouldn't have told them that
but I can do this
defending Essex
now I'm ready to start taking his pawns
you
and probably put the bishop on d5 at
some point
what is going on I can
play kini for because rook d4 um
zucchini too
I just want to play c2 c1 Queen
just let me do it
okay let's play Bishop b3
you
I think this is winning now is what does
he do he can't play Bishop a3 because I
take this rook and everything's
controlled
okay so he's going for the slide and
I can win his pawn ooh
so we have this could actually be tricky
because he's going to put the bishop on
d6
how do I win
you
okay kini for was a really bad move I
think
because I'm allowing the pawn to go
further
I think it's still winning though
somehow
because it's a light square I can always
control it with my bishop
can't control it with his bishop
not the chat
I don't want to work for
Bishop scenario because that's the
theoretical draw
[Music]
now there's no guarantee that he would
actually know how to draw it but
not gonna go into that unwillingly
nathan is back in time for the finale to
this mini Simon
um I think he's in trouble now because
Oh
oh my gosh I just got distracted by
Nathan no well at least it's a draw draw
I forgot he was attacking my rook
Bishop's move backwards
maybe he'll flag
if he flags will it give me a win
flag just so we can find out
our hidden flag
so unfortunate that's a sign it's just a
sign of carelessness and fatigue and
Nathan okay one more cycle
hey 100 bits doesn't really make me feel
better it but thank you a terrible
technique there any better way
maybe I should start with this then he
would play Bishop d6 this should be a
table based position yeah this is a
table based position check the table
base
it's winning in
DTZ
next coat the distance till the next
pawn move okay so here's what I'll do
because this is an awesome feature on me
chess which I think not too many people
know about but essentially any position
with six
I think it's six or less pieces on the
board is solved by table base and you
can access it using the opening Explorer
table base icon and then the thing here
so these are half moves so basically an
11 moves or it'll be a pawn push or a
capture so I'm just gonna click through
the line and we'll see how black wins
oh they're working on seven man nice
pink seven man exists somewhere but you
have to pay for it
so it'd be nice to have like open source
seven man and then eight man work your
way up
you answer my previous question uh what
was your previous question just paste it
in again
just gonna keep clicking and I'll look
at the chats
so it does exist but it's not easy to
access
whoa that was quick
what what is that all forcemeat oh he
could push the pawn though he six pawn
move
so we're going to keep going from here
to confuse
you
should save the pawn be seven
okay then we'll keep going from here
I think there's other table bases where
it just shows like distance until mate
now this is interesting
let's meet
and why it was forced yeah why it was
just kind of stuck that's cool
okay yeah we'll do another sigh melendi
I'm not seeing your question I can
search penny
can you explain what an intermezzo is
I've been incorrectly using Intermezzo
and zugzwang yeah so Intermezzo is the
same thing as an in-between move or as
wishing Zug or
in intermediate moon if you want to know
what Intermezzo is what you can do is go
to Lee chest org slash practice and then
go to not slugs long but go tuitions
look also known as in-between move and
then I'll leave this in the chats
someone wants to look at this
give some weird link hopefully that's
the right link anyway we'll do one more
cycle
um I'm really tired I'm not gonna make
it until
Nathan's
team-player Simon but I'll make it
through one more Simon okay Simon I
think we'll do yeah well do five five
that was manageable I'll just have to
not plunder as much
I'll be nice to people random color
again good luck to people
who's challenging me so
yeah if you guys want to play me you can
join the Simon and I'm gonna xpx
accepting random candidates in five oh
let me share the link
there you go anyone who's watching on
Twitch you have the link
okay
I think it'll be just yeah let's make a
completely random
except except that
I come from Tetris I play him already
played in the stream okay I'll play him
again
hey Chris was taken has been waiting
forever finally getting a chance I'm
accepting one more player just because
I'm a nice person
was the sky I don't even want to hurt
myself pronouncing that okay six player
Simon I've plus five
good luck to everyone
and we'll get started
this is gonna be tougher because one
more game and I think there's some good
players here to play a London
close some tabs
Philippe was p5
another a 5-game okay we have a London
playa I've been playing the petrov a lot
I don't even play the petrov in real
life
another London okay Sicilian um okay
this game I won't play the petrov let's
play this knight c6 move
it's a weird move but it's playable
oh this is a scotch interesting
h5 what a move the sky watches my stream
what do I play against h5 let's play 92
papa Cooper thanks for the follow take
with the D pawn time on of
see oh I went I meant to play c4 but too
late
we Bishop b4 check
Knight c3
see five
you
let's play the scan bit with d6
do you have to keep the tempo that's
before so we have some main line another
main line
Queen f6 gambit sideline
Queen d4 looks interesting exploited by
the sky
six
so this is all time on of theories v4
what a move
there's a visa no wait what's the theory
here with Bishop e7
yeah because he's threatening they take
b5 it's been a while take with pawn or
Bishop
I'll take with pawn because I'm open H
file
I'm not going to take on b7 just yet
you played g5
for fun Castle v5
is everyone thinking that would be nice
do this c 6d v a g5 in honor of nathan
is nathan still here um I play g5 just
for Nathan
let's play a queen here take H five so
many games with H five
you
or g4g for playable the spawns hanging
that's a free pawn
pawn it also take on d6 take on b2 first
good thread the e6 pawn
you take on e3 as well take your first
ooh
Bradon with the host 20 viewers Thank
You Bradon appreciate that
bf5 looks decent castle castle
could castle here but that would be
terrible I'll drop back with the nights
and now g4 is kind of hard to defend
this looks nice Colin Smith thanks for
the follow me six looks so enticing this
also looks enticing
conflicted I'm going to play Bishop here
and to figure out what's going on here
I could take yeah I'll just take be
pouring 95
six okay so now there is some classic
idea of trapping this rook either
starting with Bishop to c3 but I think
I'll start with Bishop c2 and then
Bishop c3 or Bishop a3
and even if he's watching he can't stop
it
um yeah let's listen to Ben Feingold
always play King V eights another free
pawn thank you
okay so he's played efore I'm very
tempted to sacrifice I'm also attempted
to play Queen f3 screen f3 actually
playable probably just a bad move
so
to take
what to do yeah I'll take why not make
it exciting
let's do this
for
so far I don't think I'm wondering
at least this is better than the last
Simon
but there's six games still going
okay so
I'm just up to pawns thanks for the one
bits
Albert HF okay I can play this and have
fun
trap
for
to play
searching for mates
where's my mates Queen b3 maybe
yeah this is actually still a very
difficult position to play
let's take on h4
over 96
we could trade what else to do
biro cure or maybe see five let's play
see five
but they reckon see it
yeah I think I've reached this point in
the cyma where I just want to improve my
rooks every game is a rook move
you
wait a minute is there a mate Queen f7
okay I'm starting with Queen f7
I don't start with Queen s7 I'm just
gonna take it's hard to stop Queen f7
you
the point 95
blocking the defense of c7 draw back the
bishop
the bishop
improve the rook prove the rook
okay now his night could be pinned in
some lines I'll take and maybe go for a
c5
ship c8 yeah Lundell the pawns increase
the pressure
I don't know what to do I'm just going
to take in 95
that's a good move be Bishop d3
it's annoying position though
what else do I do this should be for
maybe
okay this could be a very equal draw
position
but wait I can win upon take-take-take
I'm up upon it take take take and also
have a part
okay I do have to manage time though it
will trade nights
v6
before
f 3 always player 3
okay this is May than three
I should improve the queen
I sort rate anymore stuff I don't know
who the trades are benefitting Colin
Smith I'm a bit preoccupied but thank
you for the comment I just glanced and I
think that's a nice comment this pawn is
very hard pawn to defend so when you
can't defend go for counter-attacks
I play f6 always play f6 is this another
free pond he keeps giving me free ponds
now as Knights pinned let's play this
always playoff six my queen is a bit
stuck
I could take and then win two pieces for
the Queen but let's not do that
this is a bit annoying let's play 95
sacking upon weight I have to move much
quicker at five maybe
winning something
or not winning something let's just
trade trade
okay six
eh six I just play rook h6 twice d3
for attack now f5 up so many pawns but
down in so many time d2 I want to play
Knight c3 that's a hard move to stop
Knight c3 d1 let's take up on
upon kynos
care about that pawn it Queens h4 pawn
storm Oh
wait this is scary
let's get counterplay
ah that's a good move
do i sack do i do i go completely nuts
um no
okay double up
rooks belong behind pass pawns
that rook is behind both past plans
actually yeah he played f6
so sad let's do this
my time I got to move much quicker
you
this five games still going and I got
Forks No
king power king power power take the
pawn or take the Knights I guess we can
trade
mo k was simplifying
I always play f6
you
like some of these games this is too
much
c6
mmm this is really sad
eleven seconds five seconds
Oh No okay I have to put the RIP back
Bishop back
you
so at some point I'll have to decide
which games to throw away and which
games to try and fight on this is
probably a throwaway game
good move
this game I wanna fight on
you
I'm going to lose a lot of games here
No oh he played b6 I think that may have
been a mouse slip like before
so there's four games still going a lot
of okay he just gave me a pot that was
next to him
a lot of these games I'm low on time
some of these games I have a decent
positions
you
some of these games I have very bad
positions
you
no times I think
okay I've outside password potential
oh no I hung a rook how did that happen
and it ripped b7 well I have passed
pawns
and I worked at I'll help
yeah when in doubt push ponds
you
am i winning this I might be winning
this no I flagged no that was a worse
time to flag okay I have to watch for
time
it's difficult when like two players
move at the same time please don't do
that it's checking game time
push pawns ok this should be an easy win
assuming I don't flag any more time oh
no what did i do there just lost
everything
okay I still have a night
you
I'm so disappointed that that one
position I think I was winning least I'm
winning this game better be winning this
game
so I lost two games
bagged in two games this other game I'm
losing
okay
let's push the C pawn
push the e-pawn
yeah I need to choose a wiser time
control let's go to advice
you
trying to make him pink
you
yeah this is pretty sad
this is really sad
you
I don't think there's like even any more
tricks unless somehow I can find out
where where he's located and cut his
power but I don't think that would be
legal
but why is he thinking here
I'm just hoping for something I'll slip
what's not mouse if he could play
to
you can even now slip to lose yeah I
resign good game
has sad
back to Simon
yeah
um that was difficult time scramble
situation so I assume I flagged in this
game such a good position
I played such a bad move rook c4 and
then the other game I think the other
game where I wanted to play a three
final position I think black should be
winning here
a three
if he takes he too
otherwise he has no way to catch the
pong I guess he could take first I take
his night is just blocked out
anyway
thanks for the games Oh super Vijay
completely forgot theory yeah I can I
can help you remember the theory this
time-honored game this is the most
theoretical game
this is all theory this has been played
before if you look in the masters
database it's very trendy Bishop e7 so
g4 is not the move I think the move is
f4 f4 Knight g6e 5 and then the line
keeps going I think in this position Y
can choose between Bishop d4 Bishop d2
in 94
will this stream be uploaded to YouTube
let me ask you guys do you want this on
youtube I could upload it to YouTube um
alright could not I probably will
because I've been doing it recently and
been getting good feedback so I mean
it's also archived on Twitch
[Music]
but yeah so I think I'm gonna end it
here uh congrats to everyone who's being
me how's the stream she's been a lot of
people uh Osprey games well as the third
game oh this game lose this game
they're so immaculate
yeah okay so I'm adding it here thanks
guys for watching I'll be back in the
future people have been asking me my
stream schedule which it's just too hard
to schedule things when I'm traveling
and I don't know my day to day routine
until I am back home so
I might stream tomorrow but we'll see
so with that see you guys and I'll be
back in the future